an off-duty police officer in georgia is  hit by a vehicle while walking through  his yard and it was all caught on camera  take a look  2209 11 straight southeast jack brown is  a decatur police officer he noticed a  man approaching his vehicle at his home  in decatur so he walked toward it to  check it out decatur police say the  driver of a jeep identified as gregory  martin hill took off as brown approached  and hit a car in a mailbox then police  say hill tried to run over brown before  he hit a tree  that's what the doorbell camera recorded  you can see brown run toward his home he  goes inside grabs a gun and then goes  outside and points it at hill and the  jeep  get on the ground right now  [Music]  an arrest warrant says hill ran over  brown's legs as he tried to get away and  now gregory hill faces a charge of  attempted murder for law and crime i'm  angenette levy